when it comes to like love in your life
has that been a tough thing I find like
as a comedian like I get so analytical
about stuff and obviously we were
talking a little bit about how like
getting him into emotional spaces can be
like a real uh you know that can be like
a real
it's a real it can be a tough space
sometimes for comedians
um has it been sometimes I noticed even
with like being in love or something
like that I'll like I'll be analyzing it
so much it's hard for me to actually be
in the feelings yeah because I'm like
it's like to be in the feelings you
almost have to let go of some control
kind of yeah you know and so have you
had experiences like that in your life
has it been kind of tough or what's that
kind of been like because I know you've
had you've been married and you've been
married I've got two kids that's a
different kind of love it's so that's a
forever it's a love you just have it's
like it you can't choose that was that
hard for that because sometimes I fear
that like
because love seems so negotiable
sometimes I think because it was like
that when I was it felt like that when I
was a kid yeah that I worry that it's
gonna be like that if I'm a parent how
is it negotiable when you're a kid you
mean conditional you mean like it can go
away if you don't do the right thing or
something yeah yeah I think like if you
don't uh ah
yeah if you're not like
I don't know if you're not something
then
you don't deserve something you know or
something like that you know
yeah I I have a dog do you have a dog
uh-oh I've got a dog and she's like my
wife now like it's me and her you know
and uh we I mean my kids are in my life
and we have a great joy but my dog's
with me every single day when I'm home
oh wow and uh I was with my dog once and
I'd smoked I don't smoke weed very much
but I went to Washington Square Park and
just bought some weed and it was I think
it was a little a little much oh yeah
some weed makes people gay even
makes gay people look even gayer oh dude
I've never seen that no but I was uh I
was like
uh getting existential and weird you
know yeah but my dog came over and sat
with me so I just kind of hung on to her
and I said to her you know you don't
have to do anything you don't ever have
to do anything I said you don't have to
worry
you don't have to try you don't have to
be sorry you don't have to promise
uh you don't have to regret all you got
to do is sit there and just take the
love that's coming at you that's all you
got to do is just be
and just take the love that's just
coming and then I thought I could say
that to myself too I could say that's
anybody you know I mean if you're
willing to just be yourself and just sit
there yeah it's it's hard that sometimes
you're just alone sometimes you're just
lonely